hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren chris video
diese kurzvideos immer ganz gut ankam
habe ich mir gedacht ich mache einfach
mal noch allen heute widmen wir uns
nämlich dem quiz greift bist du wie
roboter steht der mädchen hinter drei
frühe reich oder irgendwas dazwischen es
manchmal gar nicht so leicht
herauszufinden wo man eigentlich steht
mein test verrät ob du deinem alter
entsprechend weit einen schritt voraus
oder gar zurück bist aber das wichtigste
ist und bleibt immer das du dir selbst
treu bistum mein gott ist das 90 x
schließlich jetzt jeder so alt wie er
sich verhält
ich dachte nicht zu
übrigens im hintergrund mal wieder so
ein bisschen aber ich hab sogar gab das
gleiche shirt an was da oben hängen
ich hab da ein bisschen aufgeräumt und
mal endlich wieder ball ukulele und
vitello ist verdeckt von balluff anfang
einfach mal mit dem quiz wird dein alter
eingeschätzt ich werde meistens genau
richtig geschätzt meistens älter zum
glück ich werde immer viel älter
geschätzt oder ich werde häufig jünger
geschätzt sei mir war es sehr lange zeit
das problem dass mich viele jünger
geschätzt haben als ich wirklich bin
weil ich früher ich zeige euch mal kurz
beim perso bild ein paar sekunden später
ok kleine planänderung ich zeig euch
doch nicht mehr so bild nicht wegen
privaten gründen oder sonntag aber meine
lampe debatte diese lampe hier mit der
ich meine videos beleuchtet die hat
schon das habt ihr wahrscheinlich ein
snapshot gesehen
das habe ich halte meine snapshot story
gepostet und gleicht diese lampe
irgendwie kaputt gemacht aber irgendwie
funktioniert wieder
ich glaube die könnte jeden moment
explodieren und da die lampe in meinem
kleinen aufnahme zimmer die tür
versperrt will ich da jetzt dran vorbei
laufen sondern jetzt lieber so 20 videos
aufnehmen und wir machen weiter was sich
allerdings mit dem versagen wollte war
das nicht total jung darauf aus obwohl
ich bei dem bild eigentlich schon 17 war
aber ist ja egal deswegen würde ich
sagen dass ich das ist dann wirklich das
erste mal dass ich mir mit seinem teste
die ich cool ist richtig mühe geben und
das ganze versuche richtig zu
beantworten
deswegen würde ich sagen ich werde
häufig jünger geschätzt wenn man die
nächste frage ich meine bei den anderen
teste ich christ bin ich immer total
bescheuert gewesen siehe beispielsweise
dieses quiz was ich euch hier verlinkt
wenn ich nicht vergesse hierzu verwenden
und wie alt bist du wirklich sitzen oder
älter ich bin auf jeden fall 17 oder
älter wie reagierst du wenn du deinen
willen nicht bekommst ich versuchs mit
guten argumenten nicht nach so langer
terror bis ich ihn bekomme ich lasse
mich auf einen kompromiss einigt druck
auf die tränendrüse
kompromisse sind eigentlich nie so mein
ding ich würde sagen ich versuche einen
guten argumenten weil wenn man jemanden
von etwas überzeugen will es ist besser
wenn ich ihn davon überzeugen dass es
sinn macht als wenn ich in ruhe oder
irgendwie anders terror mache wie weit
bist du mit einem jungen gegangen
ja es ist ein mädchen quill noch gar
nichts petting und ein bisschen mehr
aber noch keinen sex ich hatte schon mit
jungs sex küssen
ich mach mal noch gar nichts [ __ ]
vielleicht hätte ich mein erstes mal
habe ich hinter mir war aber nicht
gerade der bringer mein erstes mal von
was 62 oder contra war oder plane ich
mit meinem besten freund ich hatte noch
kein erstes mal oder wurde dabei nur
ausgeflippt war es ich würde ganz gerne
antworten ich hatte schon mein erstes
mal und es war schön aber das gibt es
einfach nicht so aus oder gibt york hat
schon ein erstes mal aber das war total
scheiße dann
was für ein erstes mal dann ich hatte
noch nicht mein erstes mal und ich hatte
noch nicht mein erstes mal was soll ich
da jetzt anklicken das verhältnis von
meinen eltern geht so aber ich habe sie
trotzdem liebt die nerven mich voll ich
hänge sehr an meinen eltern vor allem
bei meiner mutter mittlerweile wieder
besser kann ich nicht einfach sagen dass
es zu beiden elternteilen gut ist dann
sage ich halt mittlerweile wieder besser
ich weiß ich weiß nicht ich hatte auch
in der pubertät nie probleme mit meinen
eltern also zwischendurch natürlich
immer diese kleinen streitigkeiten von
wegen höhe luca du darfst nicht so lang
da raus und blabla aber jetzt nicht so
dass ich da irgendwie das ich wollte mal
ausziehen tatsächlich kurzzeitig aber
dass das war mehr so da habe ich nur
geblendet vertrauen dir deine eltern ja
total ja eigentlich schon bei einer
schwierigen entscheidung mache ich mir
viele gedanken und wege sie ab weiß ich
hoffe nicht ich höre auf mein
bauchgefühl und ich kann so was ganz
schlechtem frage deshalb meine freunde
nach rat
ich würde am liebsten das ja ankreuzen
und allerdings auch noch die einst ich
hab jetzt einfach mal die einsame kreuz
weil es bei mir wirklich so dass ich mir
bei jeder scheiß wie reagierst du in
stresssituationen bei jeder scheiß sagen
wir auch in kaufentscheidungen frage ich
mich okay macht es sinn oder nicht
selbst wenn es zu sachen sind die
irgendwie nur 20 euro kosten oder so das
ist ich weiß nicht
scheißegal muss mich ja hier nicht wenn
meine antworten recht in
streitsituationen will ich sagen und da
frage ich die ursache des streits und
wurde ich schon mal schwer enttäuscht
ich will man einfach sagen nein also ich
weiß jetzt nicht fast nicht
grundsätzlich tiefe enttäuschung ist das
kann ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
einschätzen natürlich war schon das ein
oder andere mal so dass beispielsweise
ein fußballtrainer mir gesagt hat jk
nächste spiel startelf und dann saß ich
auf der bank oder so das ist natürlich
so kleine enttäuschung oder wenn man
sich bei einer uni klausur gedacht hat
ja die waldrand kriegt man nur drei
wieder oder so aber jetzt nicht so dass
ich nicht meine eltern mir versprochen
mit mir
monat nach amerika zu fahren das ist
nicht abgefahren oder so was krasses
hatte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht was
findest du an jungs gut okay ich bin
raus ich rolle übrigens dann wirklich
immer raus wenn ich sage ich bin raus
ich rolle ist mir egal ich achte nicht
so auf jungs die nerven meistens nur
kann hier von irgendeiner gift machen
von diesem ruf der waldrand licht regt
das uns nie so hinten mit kopf und hand
also wie ich weiß wie macht man gift
schickt mir dann einfach bei twitter das
für ultra meister sehe ich eher alle
sachen die immerzu sendet wie siehst du
dich an nichts hier das an was mir steht
ich ziehe gerne ich sie wirklich
eigentlich gerade das dann worauf ich
lust habe zum beispiel jetzt gerade hab
ich in eine boxershort an ich weiß nicht
warum aber ich nehme meine videos
tatsächlich immer in boxershorts auf
kannst du mit negativer kritik umgehen
wenn es die wahrheit ist dann versuche
ich mich auch zu ändern weil ich mir
auch egal dass es schwierig negative
kritik ist immer schön aber ich versuche
es zumindest einigermaßen zu nehmen auch
wenn es nicht mag ich würde sagen dass
sich dieser typ ich bin übrigens zu
negativer kritik alles mögliche wird
glaube ich nächste woche
montag oder so eine reale topf wieder
auf einem kanal kommen bald viele sachen
gibt die mich derzeit ein bisschen hart
ab fakten und eigentlich mache ich ja
nie so info videos weil ich finde dass
man sich nicht beschweren sollte egal
was im leben passiert aber mit fakten
derzeit unglaublich viele sachen ab in
bezug auf youtube deutschland und alles
möglich und ich werde einfach mal alles
raushauen und ich werde auch eine harte
sache verändern an meinem kanal aber das
seht ihr am montag dann wahrscheinlich
letzte frage meine damen und herren
lobster an die große liebe bin mir nicht
sicher nie geht's nicht bestimmt
natürlich gibt es die ich würd sagen ich
habe mich selber meinem leben wirklich
schon drei oder vier mal so richtig
verliebt in der mädchen wo ich mir
gedacht habe
das ist krass aber da ist das halt vier
mal gab würde ich sagen es gibt keine es
gibt nicht eine große liebe zu 43 sind
sie du bist genau so reif ist deinem
alter entspricht dem us-team viele
gedanken und geht die dinge nie kopflos
an manchmal bist du verunsichert aber
das ist normal und witzig legen je mehr
erfahrungen gesammelt hat also bleib wie
du bist und lass es auf dich zukommen
dieses profil hatten 34 prozent der rund
28.000 chris teilnehmer bin und nicht
bei diesem kurs videos hängig ja
meistens noch ein zweites crestron
allerdings reicht so viel geredet hat
und jetzt in der mode taschen mal 20
minuten sind kann ich als hacker
abschätzen ist das wieder so sechs
minuten lang wird in etwa würde ich
einfach sagen das ist das war's von dem
wöchentlichen quiz wollen daraus eine
serie machen dass ich jede woche so ein
komisches chris mache oder so ich würde
mich über eine bewertung freuen falls
sie mehr davon haben wollt und
schreibt immer in die kommentare